well I traveled quite a bit then I have
for many years so I'm always aware of
like remember traveling around when I
was like basically a kid when the
Vietnam War was going on and and
witnessed firsthand anti-americanism and
I always thought you know it's
interesting to be able to stand in
someone else's shoes and look at
yourself and develop some sort of
pattern or ability to empathy or
observation and try and see the world
from through someone else's prison and
today 30 40 years later you have this
increasingly interconnected world that
has problems more acute than ever before
and I think that America has been judged
if I travel around now and you know
anyone who travels around now feels this
I mean the view about America and all
surveys would reinforce this is as low
as it's ever been I mean it's seen as
almost an imperial nation it's a nation
that you know consumes twenty-five
percent of the world's resources with
six percent of the world's population
acts unilaterally it's seen by others as
unfairly invading other countries and
seeking its will for its own material
purposes now not all of this is
necessarily true but that's the
perception that's out there and I just
think that you know when we're we're a
country with global ambition and when
you have people out there who feel that
way about you they can throw a lot of
sand sort of in the gears of what you
need to do to go about doing business
for example if you're a businessman or
to go about doing this diplomacy if
you're a diplomat and you know it's
going to take a while for us to get back
to some higher ground
and I wonder how long will it be before
people in other countries put up
pictures of the president of the united
states and their house like they used to
say in Ireland or Germany when jf
kennedy was president you know we seem
to have slipped quite a bit from that
and complicated issue i know but that's
just a fact